I was really surprised
first of all I have been enjoying
science with all my students in actually
however some kind of record in America
if you look at the faculty member
provinces in major university so-called
famous research university like MIT
Caltech Berkeley home of the Chicago
Columbia Cornell I have students former
students in all those universities among
chemistry faculty I learned that they I
produce more professors for American
Universities than anybody else so I
really enjoy doing science and by the
time in the 1980s we know that we are
doing the best because we see many
chemical reactions and many things
nobody else in the world can do so we
are very happy today we added in the
world and people from Europe from Japan
came to do postdoctoral research and
that was really as a scientist knowing
that you are doing well it's quite
satisfactory but 1986 a receiving an
award from Chemical Society Peter Debye
or Whitehouse editor master US citizens
give me the National Medal sciences and
then Noble Foundation gave me Nobel
Prize at the same time war foundation in
Israel also on the gimme the prize and I
was really surprised with life certainly
changed I was a very shy person I even
if I see a lady my my face became red
and I was very very shy but after the
prize I have to be on the limelight in
the limelight so often to develop the
dinner speech and then gradually I got
used to
but I remember during the first three
months I suffer so much so my wife said
yeah you enjoy so much working in the
laboratory was student why you have to
come to to be dinner after dinner speech
speakers and she suggested maybe we
should return to attend the price the
Nobel Foundation and you can go back to
the laboratory well